maillot de l'équipe de france ballon
mais aussi produits dérivés les
supporters se les arrachent dans cette
enseigne d'articles de sport les ventes
connaissent une progression beaucoup
plus forte que lors de la coupe du monde
de 2014
le fait que l'euro se passe sur le sol
national et danses a permis de faire
décoller les ventes ont fait de très
forte progression et le mois de juin on
peut voir une progression d'à peu près
50% du chiffre d'affaires sur le marché
des sports collectifs
nous avons paillettes et griezmann qui
sont très demandés forcément puisque les
semaines il me semble a été l'un des
meilleurs buteurs de la compétition
et voilà ce sont essentiellement ces
deux ces deux joueurs ce commerce voit
aussi une émulation autour du football
avec l'achat de produits pour des
activités extra scolaires d'ici la fin
de la compétition
il vise une augmentation de 80% du
chiffre d'affaires
une effervescence qui touche également
le secteur de la restauration
habituellement on fait plutôt avec le
avec le avec le flux est donc est le
passage donc on fait y'a pas et on a une
dizaine de réservations et on fait un
peu près 50 couverts mais donc là c'est
vraiment les réservations posés pour que
les gens soient devant la télé on l'a
déjà vécu en 2014 avec la coupe du monde
du brésil où il y avait pas mal de monde
devant cette enseigne
iny monteyne vote une progression de 30%
lors d'un match de l'équipe de france
elle enregistré plus de 70 réservations
pour le match france allemagne